this other thing i think is really
interesting so the adventure book let me
tell you about this story have you heard
do you know what this is this product
the adventure book
i have no idea what it is ben have you
ever heard of this thing
okay all right so you guys are also not
on tick tock enough this is like the
number one ad on tick tock that i see uh
i don't know if i'm just in their market
or they just run a ton of ads but
i've been seeing it for like a year
so basically it's a
it's kind of it's a book you buy
it's like a high quality big book and
what it is is like there's a bunch of
imagine like a scratch off like a
lottery so there's a bunch of things you
can a bunch of adventures that you could
scratch off so you open the book to a
random adventure you scratch it off and
it reveals a thing you're gonna go do
like it might be um
like
i don't know i've never bought the book
so like you know bad example but like
you know you're gonna go into a store
today and you give out ten compliments
to people in the store or uh you're
gonna go streaking around your
neighborhood or whatever like an
adventure a thing you can go do
and um
so this idea and and and they pair with
it like a camera so you you're supposed
to take a polaroid of you doing it so it
becomes a scrapbook so on one side it
triggers you to go do something that
you've never done or that's like you
know get you out of your comfort zone uh
and then it gives you the ability to
capture it and paste you glue the photo
in and it becomes this memory book of
all your adventures like cool kind of
novel idea so i had seen this and i was
like ah that's a cute idea that's a
novel idea what i didn't realize is this
a hundred million dollar business
that was
created in the last like two years so
how do i know this
you know like for the podcast i don't
know if you get these emails but i
definitely do
um there's a bunch of people that have
like booking agents and we get all these
emails which is like hey sean love my
first million um have you thought about
having you know
joe
joe on and you're like
you know it's like oh first
they're complimenting me so i like open
it and i'm like it's like i don't want
to be a member of any club that will
have me
you know so it's like that's how i feel
about the guest thing so normally i
write all these off but this one caught
my eye which was they said would you
like to have brian ellis on he is a high
school dropout now owns a hundred
million dollar business called the
adventure challenge and i was like it's
like that that adventure book thing and
it and so i replied i go 100 million
dollars no way that sounds high and she
goes yeah like it's been incredible
they've grown blah blah blah and i said
100 i'm just like clarify i'm like 100
million cumulative revenue annual
revenue what are you saying here
and uh and so she goes yeah like
they'll do 85 million in revenue this
year and they have a few big bigger
partnerships that distribution
partnerships that will get them over 100
um like in the next year and you know so
the business is valued over 100 million
dollars
with 85 million in revenue and i was
like what the and so i go and i
start researching this
and so here's the story
so this guy bryant he's um
so i couldn't confirm the high school
dropout part i don't know if that was
just like some post-fact like like
to make this sound better but like let's
assume it's true so uh high school
dropout i think his job was he had some
job which was like he was a skyscraper
inspector so he's like you know some low
man on the totem pole doing a job he
didn't love and he's like all right i'm
just doing this for the money
he wanted to make a business like he
just he's like my whole life i just
always been i always have ideas and and
uh you know i wanted to come create a
product it's like so i'm doing this job
and i had this idea to do um to do this
like adventure box so his original idea
was take a machine uh create a box like
a machine
and you push a button and it's like
like prints out a receipt the receipt is
like the adventure you're gonna go on so
you get like a random adventure that
comes out cool idea right
and um and so that was the original idea
and he's like ah just tells a couple
people about it and they're like oh yeah
that's cool and he's like great but he's
doing his job and he hasn't really you
know figured out exactly how to do it or
whatever um
and he's like he's like okay but he's
he's he everything's like on hold until
he gets fired from his job and he like
uh he he makes a mistake they think he
committed fraud his boss is like no no
there's honest mistake but either way he
gets fired he's like all right um
what do i want to do so he decides i
want to go to acting school so he's like
i'm going to go to acting school but i
need to pay for life so he's like i need
to create a side hustle that's going to
make me 2 000 a month that's my goal and
he's like what about that adventure box
challenge thing and he's like the idea
over the course of a few months has had
like evolved and he's like all right
what if it was actually like a book that
you could scratch off the adventure um
and so he tells a couple people about it
and they're like that's actually a
really cool idea you should do it and so
he goes to hobby lobby and he buys some
paper some of the scratch-off material
and he and he's like buys it goes to a
different store he buys a camera and
he's like starts coming up with this
idea and he basically spends six to
eight months prototyping this idea
because nobody had really done a like
kind of like um an adventure style
scratch-off book before so he's like
creating an actual physical product
and so he's like um he has this idea and
he um he just keeps telling people about
it and so he
um he gets to the point where he's
prototyped the idea several times and
there's videos i found online of like
he's creating a vlog while he's doing
he's like all right it's 11 p.m april
1st uh i just got this really cool
material for the scratch off i really
like this one but i'm having trouble
with the bindings you know and he's like
so maybe i'll try this other thing
tomorrow and then like he has the next
video you know a week later he's like
okay i figured out the bindings part and
now i need to figure out this other
thing i love seeing the the start the
early stages of these ideas
so he creates a kickstarter he's like
i'm gonna do a kickstarter it's gonna be
great i wanna raise ten thousand dollars
for this book
and uh kickstarter goes live he makes
thirteen hundred dollars the first day
and he's like yeah i'm the man he
you know goes to a coffee shop he's
strutting in he's like i made 1300 today
i don't know about you guys i'll take
you know your best give me your finest
coffee
and uh he's like all right we're you
know we're already 13 of the way the
goal let's keep going but day two
four hundred dollars day three zero
dollars and like the kickstarter like
runs out of steam he's like
i was kind of just banking on this going
viral and now it's not viral so
what now and so he's like all right
basically he's gonna throw in the towel
because like for for only seventeen
hundred dollars i can't even get the
quality of book made that i want
uh maybe i'll just quit so he's like i
need to get a job to pay for life um you
know like i'm out of money and so he's
like he's like oh maybe i'll contact my
buddy i don't forget his name but ben my
buddy ben to uh to get a sales job he
has like this company i can do sales so
he calls him up he gets a sales he's
like i want to do a sales job i want to
do it for one year
and i'm just saving up money so i go
back out there and build a product and
the guy's like alright cool that's fine
like you're upfront about it like i'm
down with that let's do it so he gets a
sales job there and while he's there
he's telling people at work this idea he
can't shut up about the idea
and um
and the guy there was like you know have
you tried ads he's like oh dude nobody
clicks ads like ads like uh ads like ads
are scams basically like that was his
mentality at the time
and the guy's like no like that's how we
grow our business like you know you
should try so he puts a little money
into ads he's like i don't know if it
worked or not but like you know i got
this like 10x roast and the guy's like
what
like no way and he's like yeah like
people really like the ad or whatever
and so the guy he partners with his
buddy the guy who hired him
and he so i'm fast forwarding some parts
of the story but basically he ends up
leaving that guy partners with him that
guy's like look we're gonna grow this
thing through ads and um and they
basically run a ton of tick tock
ads facebook ads whatever and they've
grown this thing to now 85 if this is
true 85 million dollars in sales they've
sold about 2 million copies of this book
it's like a 40 book which is like you
know something 70 something million
dollars in sales if you do the math
and um
and yeah what an adventure now they have
like a couple's book so you're like 50
fun adventures to go on with your date
they have a family book here's some
things to do with your family a friend's
book and then a by yourself book
and um
yeah it's kind of amazing